but I mean like I think
streaming is just streaming's like you
know streaming is a very interesting
space and the show is like short content
you know the way it's it's funny because
the way I see YouTube now and long-form
video content YouTube's slowly turning
into TV for the internet you know it's
slowly turning into like the old media
let's just say everyone kind of like
yeah yeah everyone it's funny because
remember when YouTubers try to get on TV
and everything now people on other
platform are trying to get on YouTube as
we all know you can't grow on Twitch
unless you have a YouTube channel that's
kind of like popping off that's the only
way to grow same with Tick Tock as well
well tick tock's an entirely different
thing but shorts don't make nearly as
much money as YouTube does so everyone
really wants to be that YouTuber so I
think that's part of the reason why
YouTube just seems like a more stable
platform now is because we forget that
in the days of the internet YouTube's
actually pretty ancient now it's been
around for a pretty long time YouTube
the only and I think mocks wrongly said
this as well it's the only stf platform
still I think no other platform feels as
polished and as good as YouTube all
right PornHub no no
there's so many scandals
that's triple s in terms of
entertainment yeah in terms of in terms
of the actual platform all right in that
case then what tier if we if we're going
by platform tier lists what would you
put twitch at right now I don't know
recent changes YouTube is
detail I mean like the interface and the
community there is great but I think
Twitter's just really been struggling to
just figure out what the [__] they want
yeah uh and it's obviously they're like
I mean I'm assuming the the the the
reason why they're kind of making these
these choices is because they're losing
money I'm guessing and I I yeah I don't
know it's just kind of like the whole 70
30 thing and they took away some 70 30
from creators yeah which um for more
background
um twitch is very uh publicly been a 50
50 company so if you subscribe to
someone you get 50 of that yep all right
yeah this is a fun game yeah yeah and
then there was a secret 70 30 uh which I
found out about maybe like after a year
of being a partner and I I you only
haven't heard about it from Word of
Mouth like some people just had it and
then you were like oh and the only way
to get it was to ask right apparently
there was like a secret criteria they
didn't talk about it was very I mean if
you're if you're a decently sized pretty
achievable uh and they had this and a
lot of the top streamers were on this
thing and I was on it for like two
months
and then they revoted it and they said
we're not doing that anymore it's not
happening we're losing too much money
yeah yeah and it was kind of a bizarre
Choice really because it only really
affected the the the top creators and
obviously the top creators are going to
be vocal and have the biggest followings
yeah so it just looked way worse than it
was and I think if someone calculated it
only actually affected like a thousand
craters right out of the whole twitch
platform which I think has like 40 000
partners and then however many others
it's a lot it's like yeah but I guess on
Twitch a lot of the power or viewership
is very weighted at the top yeah yeah
um
so they removed this and it looked
terrible for them and now they're
bringing it back and then they publicly
showed the criteria and now it looks
even worse because now they're showing
what you had to get for it and it
doesn't look good and especially for
small creators as well yeah and it
doesn't even benefit the big big
creators because after one hundred
thousand dollars which someone like
actually see what we're making in like
[__] three days you don't get in
benefit from the 70 30 anymore so yeah
it really didn't benefit many people and
it was just kind of like a weird
Band-Aid Solution on all the [__] ups
they had and then recently they they
changed all the sponsor stuff which was
like yeah that was weird because it was
like them basically Banning any events
like it's because I mean like you know
I've got the charity event coming up
which uh is happening on the 29th of
June uh yeah it's tropical so we can
talk about that yeah um and that that
would have just like uh killed that yeah
or like any kind of event like that is
done yeah yeah because that you know
these are events that often cost upwards
of six figures and it's like okay well
most people can't afford to pay that out
of pocket they need a sponsor they need
someone to help kind of alleviate the
costs yeah yeah so twitch saying hey you
can only you can't have burned in ads
into the stream which just means an ad
that plays on the stream outside of
twitch's control yeah yep
um them saying no to that is being like
we don't want anything highly produced
on our yeah so like Esports events like
you know like smash tournaments or
conventions and stuff like that but just
all be gone but obviously the caveat is
is that this is already pre-existing on
platforms like YouTube YouTube is the
same rule right uh that you can't have
ads in the video yeah oh really but it
is a nice I think it's like a it's like
a a thing that they have which they use
when someone is using it egregiously
yeah you're right well I think twitch
has two massive issues right now which
yeah PR is a big thing and part of the
reason is I think this this is what
happens when you are so reliant on such
a small percentage of your user base
right I'm the top 100 creators makes up
for like most of the user base so if
someone complains you have to listen
yeah [__] hundreds of YouTubers could
complain about a certain decision but at
the end of the day dislikes aren't
coming back they make a decision and
they stick with it no matter what you
know they have that power but with
twitch has doesn't have that same you
know have done that YouTube is the stoic
parent where it's like if I say no it's
no and which is that parent that's like
well you've been a nice boy yeah so I'll
bring it back
are you okay with your Christmas tree
you don't like it okay I can change it I
can I can change it the wise thing that
YouTube has done is obviously it's
introduce demonetization all that but
it's never [__] with the money splits
yeah I think that's just something you
just don't do yeah you don't take away
you directly say you're taking away
money from creators yeah I think it's a
disaster because then you're just you're
you're showering your creators to a
point that and no other decision could
piss them off this much than being like
hey I'm going to affect your business
model I am going to [__] you it's
literally hey how about you make it less
money now yeah yeah you have no control
what our YouTube did this with certain
things but I I think YouTube did it in
certain ways because it had to yeah you
because you know YouTube is a vested
interest in making sure you make the
most money yeah and demonetization was
there to make sure that everyone
unfortunately was like kind of a
necessary evil at the time because I
mean let's be real YouTube is in a
[__] weird place yeah when they
introduced it and it kind of needed it
it was kind of the wild west and I think
demonetization is it doesn't work
perfectly yeah it doesn't work perfectly
but it is a system that is needed in
order for the platform to be able to
grow to the size that it is now uh
twitch doesn't have that right now
twitch is still a very young platform
twitch is still in the wild west uh I
mean I feel like I don't know anymore
it's pretty [__] old uh if we're
doing like Justin TV era yeah but I mean
if you compare it to like Justin TV like
it's you know Justin TV I feel was like
the true Wild West right like because
that was that also came out during a
Time on the internet where the internet
was just the wild west but now that you
know people are taking streaming and
video platforms like YouTube and switch
way more seriously on a business side of
things as well and like a corporate side
of things now I feel especially on
Twitch like even just within like the
past couple of years I feel like it's
just gotten so much more stricter and
more like confined in what people can
actually do unless you're a massive
Creator then you can get away with a lot
of well that's that's what every social
media platform happens uh that's what
happens when a platform grows to enough
of a size yeah uh when people start
getting worried about getting sued then
you need to worry about putting in
policies and policing them which is what
we saw from YouTube when people have to
worry about advertisers dropping out
that's when people start to worry
especially like you just follow the
money and it makes sense yeah of course
something like Kik is like even more of
the Wild West than Twitches right now
but that's because it's a growing
platform yeah if it grows to enough of
the size you're going to see the same
problems that twitch is dealing with
with right now absolutely uh you can't
you can't get away from that [__]
because companies need to make money
every uh now like somehow yeah you know
it's frustrating I like yeah I like
twitch a lot of stuff [__] up I'm
really actually you know obviously I
like twitch as a platform a lot I would
just like Twitter because it seems like
everything twitch is doing right now is
reactive rather than proactive yeah yeah
it's I think that's the big problem you
never want to be reactive in a business
you always want to be like ahead of
things yes and everything they seem to
be doing is just a reaction to something
that's [__] up and it's always the
worst reaction yeah it just feels like
the people making uh some of the
decisions just feel very disconnected
from yeah what creators and viewers want
yeah
um it's just confusing yeah a lot of the
stuff makes no sense it's like what do
you why have you ever thought about
trying to stream on Kick no huh I mean
right kick is a massive PR problem yeah
the creators on there the the companies
that how would we rank kick we ranked
twitch How would
yeah that's fine but like there's a
caveat there's like the it has a giant
PR problem yes the creators on there the
the again the main the main category as
a very recent is still slots and
gambling there's a lot of a lot of
questionable stuff yeah I mean my
biggest
problem yeah I mean my my biggest
problem right now is that I don't
believe the 95.5 The okay here's okay
here's the thing right here's the thing
is unreal here's the thing
it's 95.5 now yeah but tell me how them
tell me how they're making money through
95.5 yeah because I mean there's a lot
of speculation yeah there's a lot of
speculation on different business models
but there is no actual guarantee
um and it's the oldest uh the oldest
philosophy I know of if something sounds
too good to be true most of the time it
normally is kick is this the new kid on
the block that's got this shiny dangling
like oh come to our platform it's 95.5
but let's say it does grow to the size
of twitch who's not just who's to say
that they're not going to encounter the
exact same [__] problem what's that
what's to say kick is also going to pull
a twitch and being like yeah 95.5 no
we're losing it let's pull it back to 70
30. yeah I mean right now when I see
kick I'm like go on Kick and I'm like
this is just a carbon copy of twitch
except it has gambling well yeah I think
the real money is the gambling yeah it's
gonna be more used as a vehicle for
getting people into adverse yeah I think
that's how they're making the money
right now is the fact that again like
the majority of cake right now is
gambling on sites like State I I think
it's hot it's hard to Encompass how how
lucrative gambling is it's it's very
very profitable as we all know but yeah
I think enough so that one website of
gambling would be enough to just prop up
a whole [__] chemical system yeah
easily I think so I think I think I
think it makes that much money it's
terrifying and I think obviously if
you've got more creators on it that that
could go up uh that two point whatever
billion it easily could go up I think
yeah it's like come to kick we'll give
you 955 and you can make us some extra
money by gambling on our website
funneling that back into kick so that
kick stays afloat so it's just this like
Loop of money that's going around yeah
yeah I mean I think right now it's funny
like yeah the biggest problem with Kik
is the pr problem it seems like anytime
there's an [__] doing something in
Japan or anything it's just like oh they
were streaming on Kik and I was like
great every time
every time I'm looking up news for the
second channel to be like all right
let's see uh what's been happening in
Japan today and if the if the articles
starts off with kickstream I'm just like
oh God
threatens Hiroshima on Japan and I'm
like oh God I mean that's like a huge
problem right where you think kickstream
when you should think probably a
problematic negative or someone racist
yeah I mean like that's just like that's
just not something you want yeah and I
think a lot of people don't I think a
lot of people no matter how much money
you throw them would not stream on their
platform just because of what what is
associated with it yeah I think that's
valid
um because yeah right now they just need
to clean up yeah they got to clean it up
yeah if they want like to be taken
seriously I think yeah because I think
right now of course they're making
headlines which is great they're making
headlines but and at the end of the day
it's like you need something sustainable
and the way I see what you know their
whatever their business model is
whatever their marketing is I don't know
if that's going to be something
sustained more in the long term uh
because at the end of the day you know
you look at YouTube and you look at us
who's been on the platform for a very
long time and even though the instant
nuts is a very volatile place you want
just a little bit of stability there
wherever yeah
that was the that was the main reason
why I took a twitch deal was just to
have you know I I I was just pretty
straight up I was like I went up to
church I was like hey I would like a
deal uh for XXX reason and one of the
main one being is that I want to hire
more people I want to make more events
and to do that I need a a buffer base
some money where I can be like this is
what I can spend on on Twitch this year
yeah
um and I'm totally fine with like losing
money on my twitch stuff because I
really believe in streaming and what I'm
doing right now and I'm very passionate
about it um
but also I'm not sure you're broke
so for me it was like I would like to
sign something even if it's maybe like I
know that maybe I can get more or maybe
I could negotiate elsewhere and yeah I
was like I just want to get moving with
this thing I really believe in what I'm
doing right now let's let's just do that
I think you're doing it the smart way
because you know I think a lot of you
know this is just speculation I don't
know what the fit and the mentality of
every person who gets a twitch deal is
going through but like I think you know
the way you're doing it is smart because
it's like you're using that deal and the
money you're making from that deal to
basically be like hey twitch this is
what I can do you put me on right so
it's like that that you know hopefully
if twitch is a reasonable [__]
website uh they'll look at that and
being like oh okay well then he's making
great content for us you know because of
this deal so you're more likely I feel
to bring like if I was twitch I would
look at your stuff and be like oh okay
he's someone that we I'm happy to
re-sign yeah because they're making good
stuff whereas I think a lot of people
look at like these twitch deals and
these like contract deals for streaming
sites and being like Oh I mean they're
not really innovating they're kind of
doing the same [__] some of them just
get like even lazier because they're
complacent with the money that they've
already got right yeah yeah and so you
know I look at that and being like well
then what the [__] was the point of me
giving you all this money if you're not
gonna like do anything with it